yeah we boarded that highly suspect
warship Danvers pain it was an infection
it's count so thanks for the hot tip
well you were closer yeah and now we
smell like garbage get a reading on
those tremors it was a mild subduction
under the African plate do we have a
visual how are we handling it net it's a
death quake under the ocean we handle it
by not handling it Carol are we seeing
here next month not likely what you
gonna get another haircut listen for a
face I'm covering a lot of territory the
things that are happening on earth are
happening everywhere
I'm thousands of planets yeah alright
it's a good point that's a good point
so you might not see me for a long time
all right
uh well this channel is always active so
if anything goes sideways anyone's
making trouble where they shouldn't
comes through me okay
[Music]
I don't think I want you looking at that
I'm not sure it pertains to you anymore
now this on the other hand is agent
Romanovs assessment of you read it
personality overview mr. stark displays
compulsive behavior in my own defense
that was last week prone to
self-destructive tendencies I was dying
I mean please and aren't we all
textbook narcissism agreed okay here it
is a recruitment assessment for Avenger
initiative iron man yes I got to think
about it read on Tony Stark not not
recommended that didn't make any sense
how can you approve me but not approve
me I got a new ticker I'm trying to do
right by pepper I'm in a stable and fish
relationship which leads us to believe
that this juncture we don't like to use
you as a consultant
you can't afford me
then again I will waive my customary
retainer on exchange for a small favor
rody and I are being honored in
Washington and we need a presenter let's
see what I can do
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my blacc panther2 name or easter egg
video there been a couple Easter eggs
for Atlantis and Namor in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe going all the way
back to Iron Man 2 so we'll break it
down and I'll explain why black panther
2 is a Marvel phase 5 movie in not on
the Marvel phase 4 schedule we're doing
the Avengers end game and spider-man far
from home blu-ray giveaways all you have
to do to enter those is be a subscriber
and leave your best Namor theory on the
video Namor is a perfect character you
can introduce as a black panther villain
the same way they introduced the mbaku
character in the Black Panther movie
first he shows up trying to fight the
throne away from Black Panther just
because their ideologies are so
different their bitter enemies then
become allies I wouldn't call them
friends but they're definitely much more
friendly than they were before in mbaku
became king of Wakanda after both Shuri
in Black Panther got snapped so during
that scene Black Widow is asking a coy
way about an underwater earthquake off
the coast with all kinds of tremors and
aftershocks they didn't spend a whole
lot of time during the movie explaining
what happened in Wakanda during that
five-year time jump between the end of
Infinity Ward Thanos his first snap in
the Avengers endgame final battle mbaku
then became the strongest candidate to
take the throne as king of Wakanda
Okoye is still doing the same thing but
with 50% of wakandans around she has
more responsibilities on her hands but
both of them are staunch traditionalists
when it comes to Wakanda and culture in
society
remember mbaku hated the idea of
technology initially even though he may
have softened a little bit on it he's
still very stuck in his ways a coy way
is the same way too she was all about
protecting the history of Wakanda black
panther was making the radical move at
the end of the Black Panther movie to
open their borders and start the
outreach programs so you have the
perfect scenario with post snap Wakanda
going back to closing its borders off
again because of the tragedy we need to
take care of our own so they're not
doing quite as much outreach as they
would have done before being more
isolationist outside of participating in
these Avengers global threat watch
meetings but they're mostly dealing with
all the
laziness that's going on inside
wakanda's borders then you have this
giant underwater earthquake Atlantis is
partially or mostly destroyed after
they've already lost half of their
Atlantean population to being snapped
away and Namor not fully understanding
what happened between the Avengers and
Thanos to cause all of it so basically
you have the same thing happening to the
Atlanteans and Namor that happened to
Thor in the Asgardians first a whole
bunch of them get killed off then half
of those that survived gets snapped he
had the five-year time jump with them
trying to pick up the pieces now you
have the same thing happening in
Atlantis in Atlanteans already hates
surface dwellers and are even more
isolationist than what Conda was Namor
lives through all these tragedies one of
the key differences between Namor and
other Marvel Cinematic Universe
characters is that he's very very
long-lived so he's been king of Atlantis
for more than a thousand years and you
have black panther a brand new king so
you have the idea of two kings going to
war with each other and wrestling with
what it means to be king but also
dealing with all the craziness that's
happened between Avengers infinity war
in Avengers endgame then you have a Koi
a over here like you know there's an
underwater earthquake in the ocean who
gives a crap not our problem that is
what caused a lot of the problems that
they dealt with during the first black
panther movie you have black panthers
father and his brother fighting each
other his father eventually kills his
brother because he stole the vibranium
because he wanted to help other people
black panthers father said that he felt
like it was too risky and they had no
business getting involved in the rest of
the world's problems and that leads them
to their kill monger plot so named or
just a slam-dunk Black Panther villain
in that same vein some of the similar
ideas from the first Black Panther movie
but just on a much more massive scale
dealing with much more complex internal
problems Black Panthers storyline
mirroring nemours storyline as kings of
their respective nations and what it
means to be king in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so why is it Namor on the phase
4 schedule Black Panther made
gangbusters money how come they aren't
rushing to get the Black Panther sequel
out Kevin Feige said is mostly because
Ryan Coogler is still working on the
script they gave him four years to
develop that sequel and that took him a
little while to sign ryan coogler for
the sequel they didn't lock him down for
a second movie when they did the first
Black Panther movie so he's gonna get
crazy money now best rumor I've seen so
far is that it's gonna come out May
20-22 and be an early Marvel phase 5
film with guardians of the galaxy vol 3
it was such a big film they didn't want
to rush a bad sequel out when they could
take their time and make something way
better normally it would be like three
years but you have all this stuff with
Thor for being tail and Marvel phase
four so they just do wait a little bit
longer to release it but the other big
reason why they're waiting on it just a
little bit is because of Namor the
Atlanteans people with biologically
based powers very close to the ideas of
x-men and mutants and they're just not
quite there in the MCU yet Scarlet Witch
is just the tip of that iceberg because
there have been some of official Marvel
books that have described her as having
latent biological powers which is
basically them saying she's a mutant
without coming right out and saying that
she's a mutant but these books were
published before the Fox Steel went down
now Marvel can say anybody's a mutant
that they want to without any big legal
problems but they're using the Eternals
movie early Marvel phase four to explain
biological powers in the MCU and
typically Marvel introduces a big
concept like that in the movie before
doing movies that trade on similar plot
twists Doctor Strange is probably the
best example of that in the first Doctor
Strange movie they introduced the
concept of the multiverse and they
explained how magic in the supernatural
works in the MCU once they did the
supernatural as Kevin Feige explained
during the big Marvel phase four panel
it allowed them to do blade a vampire
and multiverse movies like Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness and
then you know next step on that road
once they established all that they had
the foundation for their Avengers Secret
Wars multiverse movie amazing story
potential but you can't do something
like that until you explain a couple
other really big concepts in other
movies same thing with the x-men mutants
Namor and people with biologically based
powers
that's why Fantastic Four x-men the
blade movie Black Panther two are all
Marvel phase five movies not Marvel
phase four right now there's a rumor
that Marvel is going to announce some of
their Marvel phase 5 movie dates at the
d23 panel in a few weeks if they do that
of course I'll do a video for it they're
probably gonna show off some footage
from the Marvel phase 4 movies too right
now these are the rumors for the early
Marvel phase 5 movie dates I mean it
makes
the Black Panther - and guardians of the
galaxy three would be some of the first
Marvel phase five movies because
guardians already has the cast and they
have a finished script but let me know
in the comments if Namor is the villain
of black panther - what do you want them
to do with the character after that
movie because I just don't see him
joining the Avengers anytime soon in fun
fact - right now the Aquaman sequel is
coming out at the end of 2022 so will be
fun to see what happens when those films
go head-to-head or they decide to move
the release date of the Aquaman sequel
but I'm working on more Marvel phase
four videos and Eternals preview video
Fantastic Four and x-men videos if
there's any big questions or requests
that you guys have for videos just leave
them in the comments below
congratulations to the winner from my
last big spider-verse video Nick papel
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here to learn about the
live-action spider-man venom
spider-verse
TV shows they're making and click here
to learn about the Red Hulk deleted
scene from Avengers endgame thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you